hello and welcome to the new world of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today we are here for some
hunter hunter related fun times quite
specifically to discuss the ever
controversial hypothetical of what would
have happened in the event that adult
gone fought against the ant
king marowan not at all a simple topic
to cover and one that comes with its
fair share of confusion and
misinterpretation which is bound to pop
up in a series like this where the
author you know isn't generally
concerned about power and combat but is
instead
interested in other ideas ideas that are
not power in combat
and actually one of my favorite fun
facts about hunter hunter is that almost
every major fight in the series has been
a completely one-sided affair where the
winner was never realistically in doubt
so we really don't get a lot of truly
equal match-ups and as such it's kind of
a shame that that or gone and meruem
never came face to face because they do
present the pinnacle of raw aura use in
the series but then again
would a well-balanced fight even have
ensued well we're here to explore
exactly that and in order to do so we're
all going to need to take a page from
the book of gone and enhance ourselves
by subscribing to the new world review
which will result in regular hunt onto
content being uploaded straight into
your youtube feed but let's get why into
this topic exists in the first place
i'm sure it was probably still fairly
debated before but the whole adult gone
vs marowan hypothetical really does stem
from the 2011 anime adaptation of hunt
hunter and it's all because of
one line from neferpito where while gone
is transforming they state
i was right his power is now equal to
that of the king
and that is an extraordinarily clear-cut
statement and i really don't blame the
anime-centric part of the fanbase
for simply taking this at face value
especially for a shonen series where
there's always this subconscious
understanding that characters are not
just conveying information for their own
benefit
it's designed not only to speak to
themselves or another character but also
to speak directly to the audience and
when you get into
darker more adult-oriented content this
can change quite a bit by introducing
things to deliberately mislead or
misinform the audience
such as an unreliable narrator and
that's kind of where hunter hunter
actually lands during the chimeran talk
the series very much began its life as a
standard
shonen where every piece of information
could be implicitly trusted however over
time it morphed into something else and
almost every character is now an
unreliable source of information
so when in the anime pito states that
gon's power is now equal to that of the
king that is not
a decree that has been set in stone this
is pito's personal opinion which is
flawed because they don't actually know
the full extent of merome's power nor do
they really grasp the true scope of
adolcons all pitot really knows in this
instant is that both arogon and meruem
are on a level
beyond peter themself and i think that
the manga did a far better job of
portraying pito's feelings on this
matter because in the manga pito's line
was
as i feared his fangs might even sink
into the king which is
completely counter to the anime in the
manga pito is expressing a vague concern
they have no way of quantifying gone as
a threat pito simply senses the
potential of a threat
which to a member of the royal guard is
a matter to be taken with the utmost of
seriousness however there is no talk
whatsoever of being equal to the king
so i just wanted to start by breaking
this myth of equality before we move any
further forward
pito never expresses equality
canonically through the manga and even
if they did
pito's opinion is unreliable however to
have some fun with that you could
potentially even make the argument that
pito is still underestimating gone at
this point and that perhaps he is still
quite close to meruem in terms of power
but we do need to make that assessment
through other means
so firstly let's take a look at meruem
and to be clear we are talking about
meruem prior to absorbing pufa yupi
because what he goes on to become is
essentially a god-like entity and there
is no discussion to be had there
whatsoever
in fact things are kind of tough enough
with just our base for meruem who is the
only character in the entire series who
actually can't be ranked in the hunt
hunter manual because if you take a
brief look at his stats you'll notice
that almost everywhere is a complete
question mark with the exception of one
of the palace invasion set of stats
where everything is five plus which does
very little to clarify anything and
tells us that his capabilities may as
well be infinite on the scale now to put
this into some perspective merome's
primary opponent isaac netro ends his
time in the series with a perfect five
out of five score for each area but even
base four meruem is clearly above that
classification and just while we're
talking about stats i should say that
adolgon does not appear to ever actually
be ranked according to the system
because as far as i can tell all of
these figures refer to regular gone but
for meruem this still tells us quite a
bit in his base form he has
unbeatable well everything speed stamina
strength or
intellect you name it and meruem has
literally all of it
and you have none of it and i do think
it's important to highlight the idea
that marowan was quite deliberately
created as a character who would be
impossible to overcome by traditional
means because
well we tried that we threw humanity's
greatest warrior at meruem and we even
condensed every last drop of his aura
into one gigantic blast and it still was
not enough to do really anything beyond
superficial damage
everything about meruem is intended to
be unbeatable which isn't something we
can really ignore in a hypothetical like
this because for gone to come out on top
here he would essentially need access to
an infinite reserve for power capable of
meeting togashi's intentions behind
meruem but just one more thing regarding
marum there are a lot of minor instances
in the series where people
attempt to bring maorim's abilities down
to some form of reality one of the more
notable ones is right after his birth
where he tail whipped pitot with the
intent to kill them and this event is
something that i often see cited as a
limit to merome's physical power it's a
very poor argument though because having
the intent to kill does not mean using
every ounce of your strength to
accomplish it the situation was more
akin to a human spotting a fly the fly
is being annoying so yes you have the
intent to kill it but that doesn't mean
that you punch it with all of your might
with that said all of meroram's
attributes will have a limit we just
aren't aware of what that limit is
because there was nothing in hunter
capable of pushing him to that point
which takes us to gone his adult form
much like marowan is an existence that
is extraordinarily difficult to quantify
the basic gist of the form is that gon
made an envow to access all of the power
he would ever have so what we're looking
at is a snapshot of what would have been
the future eventually gone would have
become a frankly unstoppable or a beast
and not only that but gone also grew to
physically surpass nephipito by an order
of magnitude which wouldn't have been so
difficult in terms of strength because
that comes quite handily with natural
enhancement but a very underrated aspect
about
gone is his speed and agility
particularly as pito is the most agile
of the three royal guards so seeing them
completely out class speaks volumes as
to what gon is capable of
and i really don't think it's out of the
question to put gone on relatively
the same playing field as base meruem in
that regard although there's no great
way to compare because the only other
two characters who outclassed pito's
speed were meruem himself and netero the
latter of whom having a particular level
of speed that not even meruem could
quite catch up to in the end not in his
base form anyway now before turning to
strength i think it's a bit more
important to consider aura because as a
natural enhancer that is more or less
going to directly convert into strength
for gone and the interesting thing about
the out of gone form is that it's not
clear if it has aural limitations mostly
due to killer's assessment of the
situation that the more oregon used in
this form the higher the price he would
ultimately need to pay perhaps meaning
that in theory gone could just keep
pushing into infinity kind of similarly
to alaka or i guess nanika's ability
they can make anything happen so long as
an equal price is paid although even
with that in mind i do strongly believe
that there would have been a strict
limitation somewhere with gone given
that he was only able to offer himself
up his payment still the aura reserves
that allocon possesses a pretty out of
control and will put him on a level of
strength comparable to that of meruem
via natural enhancement which by the way
is the one and only mild advantage that
gone actually has over marowan because
meruem is a natural specialist
so enhancement is by far his weakest
affinity meaning that there is a lot of
potential for gond close whatever that
power gap is with his natural boost
because it would basically cost meroem
several times as much aura as gone to
achieve the same effect and now
something else that will often get
brought up in regards to gone would be
the fact that pito did manage to sever
one of his arms or at least pito's
post-mortem post-moltemnen corpse thing
did this doesn't have any real impact on
his strength or durability because it
occurred at a moment where gon had
completely let his guard down
he thought that pito was dead and he was
an emotional wreck so no aura was being
expended to keep an eye on his
surroundings or defend himself and in
that situation
he suffered the same consequence as
anyone would have including meruem and i
suppose that brings us to where this
fight is ostensibly lost or won
and rather unsurprisingly for hunter
hunter it is entirely in the mental
arena because i do think that an
argument can be made that it is possible
for gon to have the strength speed and
aura reserves to take mariemon however
what he does not have
is the intellect to use those abilities
to actually overcome marijuana and this
isn't to say that gone is an air-headed
punch machine i actually don't think
gone gets anywhere near enough credit
for his intelligence he can be quite a
little genius in combat as shown time
and time again with particular examples
coming to mind being both against
genthru and knuckle however gone is a
very instinctual combatant
he acts based on more primal senses and
information which to be fair worked
phenomenally against nephipito gone
senses were unbelievably sharp in their
brief conflict and it really gave him
this truly invincible vibe however in
this case that would be pit directly
against meroram's strategic prowess
which is unmatched by all of humanity
well with one exception and only when it
comes to gungi specifically
marowam does have a greater advantage
though because his ridiculous
intelligence isn't all he has to rely on
being a chimera aunt he is also well and
truly in touch with the same sort of
primal instinct that gone heavily relies
on so gone doesn't have any particular
advantage there either oh and also we
should very much examine the motivation
of both characters because usually in
hypothetical combative discussions
that's less than relevant but the thing
to remember here is that the adult gone
form does not occur naturally this is
gone's response to the greatest despair
that he has ever felt in life as well as
his acceptance to relinquish his life
and i think that is best encapsulated
with the following line enough
let it end i don't care what happens to
me now i need all the power i'll ever
have which paints gone quite accurately
as a reckless revenge driven individual
which is a terrible match-up against
someone like meruem whose overbearing
sense of duty for his race will always
be able to overcome a self-destructive
mentality because really when it comes
down to it gone is fighting to die
whilst meruem is fighting to live and in
that situation both combatants would
achieve their goal making meroem the
easy winner and i do bring this up
because there is also a very common
misconception that gone transformed
because pito backed him into a corner
and threatened to kill him the general
logic being that this transformation was
more of a survival mechanism kicking in
and i really can't count the amount of
times that people have tried to tell me
this
but it's wrong during this conflict with
pito gone had one concern and that was
reviving kite once that became an
impossibility
gone made the decision to throw away his
life in order to take revenge
like he quite literally states that he
doesn't care what happens to himself the
thought of survival is so
far removed from what arogon is that he
would have been swiftly dissected by the
superior intellect and instinct of
meruem so the only path out of gon would
have to victory in this sort of
situation would be to have the strength
speed and aura so superior to meroems
that strategy becomes meaningless which
he certainly does not
so no matter what way we look at it this
encounter would greatly favor meruem
even if we were to accept the
hypothetical that gone's physical
abilities equally match those of the
king
because even in that situation the
mental mountain is simply too high for
gon to climb and that's probably one of
many reasons why togashi elected not to
have such a match-up in the series but
what do you guys think please do leave
your thoughts in the comments below or
even join my discord server and if
you're keen for some more hunt on
content then please to go and check out
some of my other videos or even
subscribe to the channel for regular
hunt hunter glory delivered straight
into your youtube feed but for now this
has been the new world review
and i'll see you next time